it's insurrection part two as dozens of
rioters descend into the oval office as
the president and vice president are
taken by surprise look at the chaos oh
my god can you help the fbi dear viewers
identify the insurrectionists our
democracy is at stake this is worse than
watergate 911 in pearl harbor
of course that's madame tussauds new wax
replicas of our president and vice
president it's the first time those two
have been seen together in months
plus those wax figures have already held
more press conferences
but also with joe this might be the
first time to sew
wax figure is more lifelike than its
inspiration
they tell me joe's figure was actually
made out of his own earwax
he's been collecting it in a mayonnaise
jar for years not the only one cat
speaking of wax figures did anyone catch
cold bear the other night
no
well if laughter caused cancer his
audience has been in remission for 10
years
talk about a change of heart however
remember how he was terrified that under
trump all our precious institutions
would be destroyed well donald's gone
and the only folks craving destruction
are democrats including dear steven yeah
it started with statues and it's never
stopped
if you can't get rid of the filibuster
what about and just hear me out here and
try to do this objectively i'm ready
what if
we just get rid of the senate
and i'm 100 serious here it is the most
anti-democratic institution
next to the judiciary because the
judiciary is only the way it is because
the senate is the way it is i'm thinking
the only thing that should be abolished
is colbert's writing room
damn that was even too crazy for liz
warren she was ready to send a smoke
signal to the tribe to come rescue her
so all the people screaming about
threats to our republican attacks on our
democracy are now upbeat about burning
it all down they're happy about
executive order forced vaccination
they're thrilled about the government
working with big tech to censor dissent
they're a-okay with harsh treatment by
the doj over political opponents and why
because they love power but they can't
persuade and when you can't persuade you
change the rules or you enforce new ones
colbert is that guy you're beating in a
monopoly game so he flips the board over
and he wants to abolish the senate
because that abolishes the power of the
states and leads the power to the
dirtbags in dc chicago san fran la and
nyc
and you've seen the good job they've
done with their cities right those
cities are disastrous because they
thought tearing down statues was a
bigger priority than subway shovers they
thought people cared more about trans
bathrooms than train robberies they
thought pitting people against each
other was superior to protecting them
from maniacs so while the country
lurches into a dark abyss
biden once again divides us tweeting
about jim crow 2.0 again falsely
claiming that one half of the country is
preventing the other half from voting
and then he offers no evidence instead
it's just racial smears this guy plays
the race card more than hunter plays
with himself
and judging by the laptop that's nothing
to shake his stick at
joe claims
the bill
is meant to prevent election fraud but
weren't we told that mentioning fraud
undermines public faith in elections
and besides wasn't 2020 a perfect
election my guess it's bs they really
want ballots to be as insecure as the
view in a spin class
frankly i'm confused by all this
misinformation so thank god for cnn
they're hiring new staffers to fight
fake news the only thing you need to do
to land a job over there is a trench
coat a bag of candy and working
knowledge of the local playgrounds
on twitter alex koppelman announced cnn
is creating a new team dedicated to
covering false news that should be easy
they'll never have to leave their own
building all they're investigating will
lead them to jeff zucker's office
it's kind of like alec baldwin teaching
gun safety koppleman says it's about
covering the uses and abuses and
distortions of reality if that's true
then start with the three c's championed
by cnn collusion covington crime
it'd probably spell kyle rittenhouse
with a c for how much they lied about
him then throw in some kavanaugh smilet
those crazy stories about don jr meeting
with shady russians
you got your first year wrapped up and
let's not forget how misinformation is
made by hiding the news from
underplaying riots to hiding hunter's
laptop to mocking the murderous crime
wave all covered up by cnn
so they're also hiring reporters the
kind who quote feel like you have to
jump down every rabbit hole you see the
kind who spend more time on the internet
than anyone really should
basically they're looking to hire that
400 pound guy sitting on his bed as
trump would say losers too fat and lazy
to join antifa but i feel for the poor
staff like brian stelter putting on
leggings they're gonna have to work
overtime to cover themselves
i just wonder how they're gonna do it
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
david brooks for chess news network i'm
outside our new york city headquarters
we receive reports of someone spreading
misinformation it has not been
adequately fact checked we believe it
could lead to a hubbub possibly brew
haha or worse independent thought let's
take a look
peter pawn what the hell
[Music]
pan here chess news network's number one
reporter investigating reports of a
journalist spreading misinformation hey
russ not the number not the number one
reporter peter pan
brenda bishop here with the chess news
network where we've identified two
possible sources of misinformation back
to you grant
name's greg but anyway
but
finally at least there's some good news
for everyone especially those in new
york
so this is the right place for me to
share some news with you no i am not
going to be running for governor new
york state
like he ever had a chance
so de blasio won't be running for gov
and also i won't be participating in the
slam dunk contest at this year's nba
all-star game
bill you hardened fussy clump of
excrement thanks for letting us know
even though nobody asked
like godzilla's stomping through tokyo
you destroyed a city and now you're
jobless so here's an idea go work at cnn
you can't kill something that's already
dead
[Applause]
welcome tonight's kiss
his friends call him the hammer because
they don't know how to spell
america's newsroom co-anchor bill hammer
he's like a real-life jack bauer not
because he's former cia because it takes
him 24 hours to complete a sentence
former cia operative and hosted the
black files declassified on discovery
science channel well that's obscure mike
baker
and if he's here rob schneider's taking
the night off actor writer and comedian
jamie lissau
finally like an analog clock she's got a
pale face two skinny arms and is hated
by children
foxy's contributor cat time
bill hammer as always the sexiest man
alive in my version of people magazine
so isn't it cnn opening an anti-fake
news like bureau whatever you want to
call it that is like me deciding to
crack down on poop jokes
i mean that's all i do that's all they
do is churn out fake news i i guess it's
not going to end well no i mean how
would they cover hunter biden's laptop
would they do it the same way twitter
did yeah i cancel the new york post i
have a theory yes um i i saw that
they're looking to hire three people
in about a month's time i think it's
exactly 32 days from now
trump goes online with his own social
media network right so my theory is that
this group is going to be set up to
counter just about everything trump puts
online oh now you have your own branch
and division to counter what will be
known as truth social i think that's the
name of this so
there is the theory and we'll see
whether or not that that's a really you
know that's why you're so smart and that
you're on the news side and i'm here
right because i could be wrong no you're
never wrong bill you're never wrong like
you're never ugly you know though
you made me think that like if they're
hiring three people can you identify as
more than one person because like you
can identify with this anything i'm
gonna start identifying as three
different people you know jamie i bet
you have some pr some very perceptive
analysis on the uh
uh madame tussauds wax muse wax museum
figures of our president and vp i would
like to hear them from you that's a
great question from both of you greg
thank you
um
yeah i i have one thing great i think if
someone makes a wax statue of you
and it looks healthier than you do you
should immediately go to the hospital
yes
like if it looks better but i guess this
thing's super accurate like it's the
same
it's the same exact height down to like
a millimeter of biden it's the same
density and weight and it also has the
same amount of great ideas
that's so cool
i heard jill went down there and now she
pictures wax joe biden during sex
um so far three for three
do you want to stop now this is like who
wants to be a millionaire
okay there was just there was just so
much there in what you said i mean
there's just so much like the i had one
quick thought on colbert which is did
you notice he says the thing about
what he says the senate and then the
crowd laughs yes thinking it's a joke
and then remembers oh this is the
colbert show there's no laughing
like they almost like had to catch
themselves really bizarre that's why he
said he had to come up and go i'm deadly
serious about that that's why like i
wasn't going to run an angle but once
you say that no i'm serious about it
mike you look great you look like ethan
very much i'm just trying to keep up
with bill the hammer hammer yeah you're
like ethan hawk's granddad
wilfred brimley yes
so what do you there's a lot to chew
from this monologue i'd like to hear a
lot of thoughts uh if you could if you
could form the thought in kind of a
coherent statement where there's a
subject and a verb
object so you want full sentences yes i
want full sentences okay let me try uh
first with colbert i agree i mean i
think
i think it's been a long time since
anybody's laughed at colbert but i i go
to him for all my knowledge of the
constitution and how the federal
republic is supposed to work but
when you
what he says about just shutting down
the the senate yeah if you go and troll
through social media the sheer number of
people out there who actually have the
same
concept right is is remarkable people
they're just basically saying if at any
point in time the current administration
or
the group doesn't agree with me
we just want to change those rules yeah
and the other thing i would say is is
with with uh president biden
um
are we going to talk about his press
conference yes it's in the b block i
don't know i don't read these things
nobody tells me anything oh no oh blame
my blame my producer he's blaming my
staff look i can't i can't help you
about the pci
i just fired my staff because you said
that okay fine well let's see see i've
done my job
so no i i didn't know i just got in from
los angeles where we've been filming uh
black foster classified which is of
course going into its second season in
early march on discovery you are
fulfilling the intro that i had for you
there you go
jack bowers 24.
so cat i keep looking at cnn like
somebody with a huge blind spot right
they don't know when they're doing this
how funny it is it's like a guy with the
world's worst toupee and everybody looks
at it but he's oblivious and actually
he's living a pretty good life because
he is oblivious actually bad toupees are
better yeah yeah i think it's great i
appreciate a really bad toupee
um all too
for example
i got rid of the one with the chin strap
you shouldn't have it's too tight um all
that aside yeah absolutely but they
don't have to because they don't care
clearly i mean their ratings are way
down and instead of again trying
something new they're like let's go in
harder on this one remember the whole
like this is an apple right we'll just
tell you it's an apple we only have the
facts here how many times have they been
wrong i've lost count of how many times
i've been wrong and they're just instead
of saying hey you know a lot of this you
know this isn't a news anchor this is
actually an opinion host and kind of
acknowledging those sorts of things no
they're going to be the ones you know
standing against misinformation they
have this self-important attitude if it
wasn't for them nobody would know what
was true if it wasn't for see it and
nobody even watches it i know you're
only the only people that watch it are
by accident but the
last point because we got a role is that
it seems to me that misinformation now
is the new hate speech so it's not like
if you say something wrong it's like
words equal deeds so they say that now
misinformation is deadly and that builds
the case for cracking down on it which
is what they're doing to fox you know or
anybody else that that beats beats the
pants off them well by the way they'd
like to get their pants beaten off from
those perverts there's a difference
between misinformation and
disinformation too and look i spent a
lot of time overseas yes in some very
unusual places yeah and
where where there is a there this is the
way the governments in those places work
yeah they will tell you what is correct
and what is not yes and
if if we don't understand how dangerous
this is i mean i know we're making fun
of it and because it deserves to be made
fun of in a sense
this is a very dangerous
path for us to be going on this idea
that the president of the united states
would be saying you know all your news
networks you gotta you gotta you know
shut down this misinformation that is a
that's something i would hear when i was
overseas in a fourth world cup it's like
i mean could you imagine some president
going hey you back there you're fake
news yeah imagine that
no
that wouldn't happen yeah hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else